star trek into darkness this movie is
action-packed when I say this movie is
non-stop action I won't fight you're
like he action can you stop everyone's
are talking a lot about benedict
cucumber this guy is [ __ ] awesome
major [ __ ] scene stealer perfect
villain same time he's kind of a
charming mother [ __ ] I would totally
suck Benedict's cucumber young William
Shatner is [ __ ] awesome in this movie
him is Captain Kirk brilliant funny
charming most beautiful eyes in the
world ah he is a great lead actor
Zachary Quinto is really good as Spock
he gets to kick way more ass in this
film some people are complaining about
whether or not you know they should keep
exploring Spock's human side or not I
personally love exploring Spock's human
side cuz movies also loaded with a bunch
of humor at the same time it doesn't
cross the line of being a comedy all the
humors within the context of the
characters more like star trek into the
Laugh Factory the visual effects are
orgasmic you're probably asking yourself
how can visual effects be orgasmic well
look at my seat seat number m17 at
Universal CityWalk and you will see it
is filled with all of my semen the
production design is top notch some of
the best production design i've seen in
a long time Simon Pegg also does some
great standout work as Scotty really
funny really Scottish there's a
wonderful cinematography and yes you
annoying [ __ ] there is the lens
flare the last great thing I got to
mention there's a lot of great [ __ ]
music in this film and there are some
cons to the film the last act of this
film seems a little bit bombarded just a
lot of Danger Danger Danger Danger but
don't really get a sense of tension
there and plus the ending feels very
rushed there's also some unexplored plot
points I can't really get into right now
because I be a major spoiler and overall
there's a lot of drama in it I didn't
really find the trauma to be that
impactful mainly because they don't
really get to explore the characters as
much as I did in the first one I really
feel like if you have not seen the first
Star Trek you will not give a [ __ ]
anyone in this film now even though they
don't really get to explore the
characters as great as they did in the
first one there's still a lot of great
stuff in here let me get straight to the
point here all in all i gotta say start
shaking a darkness got it right alright
guys thanks for checking out my show
once you go ahead scroll that comment
box below and tell me what did you think
about star trek into darkness or which
one is your favorite star trek go ahead
put some spoilers down there piss off
people who haven't seen the movie
already and you want to see more in
depth review of star trek into darkness
go ahead and check out my show they do
my buddy Jerry called reasons to see
where we have special Mexican guests
starting to show cue on the show and
last not least if you want to get
updated every time one of my reviews is
out go ahead and subscribe to my channel
on the link right there